leadership labs is a transformational
experience one of my issues that I faced
before I came here was being conflict
averse when it came to talking to
someone about their performance or just
an overall difficult conversation I
didn't know where to start then I
learned about the leadership labs
program here at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business the leadership
program is a program that places you at
seven other MBA ones and you simulate a
real-life executive environments layoffs
hiring and firing it's different from
sitting in a classroom and learning
about how to talk through these
conversations it's about actually
practicing it so when you face it in
real life it's not a surprise some of my
best friends have come from that room
that environment were region pushed to
challenge ourselves time and time again
so the leadership labs culminates into
not your typical final exam it's called
the executive challenge where the school
flies back hundreds of its top alumni
CEOs partners managing directors from
all these firms across the globe and
these executives challenge you with
real-life cases I actually won the case
and now I'm a leadership fellow I'll be
a second-year MBA who steps in and
trains first-year MBAs on those exact
same skills that I was looking for prior
to coming to the Stanford GSB
naturally with a Stanford MBA you're
going to be placed in situations where
you're expected to lead I for instance
want to work in general management with
large corporations and I know that
there's a stereotype for what a CEO or
for an and the executive looks like and
I don't naturally fall in that category
I'm a female I'm african-american I'm
short but with these leadership skills
there's going to be no doubt that I'm
fit to lead these organizations
you